you
oh man here we go you got to go quick
make fast moves three seconds is what
you start out with okay
I'm in time pressure my opponents in
time pressure back to tournament they
weren't quick enough three seconds with
wait can you go berserk you could still
go berserk oh you should definitely go
berserk or maybe no not would increment
time controls you can't go berserk oh
that's oh that's a piece I'm gonna take
that let's kick him out of there two
seconds just make any ol move here no
matter what they're down on time back to
tournament you get a lot of games in no
you can't go berserk you can't go in
berserk if if there's increment I think
that's what it is okay
hit that Bishop okay they have a ruin
their pawn structure is really ruined I
have this square for my knight and I
should have taken the bishop maybe
they're down on time back to tournament
you gotta go quicker three games in two
to four 12 time remains Wow Wow
okay your first few moves really have to
be quick
oh I'm getting a piece sometimes it's
just tough to even go with those
long-range moves oh I had a piece there
they're not taking that I gotta break
this pin they're getting that I'm still
material though hit the rook I only have
one second back to tournament Oh four
games in
and we're only two minutes in the game
my goodness ah this is too much this is
too much
yeah this might be the first and last
one of those first and last tournaments
oh it's just too quick it's too quick a
tournament I'm gonna anchor my knight in
there
I gotta go faster they're gonna kick me
away
let's take no no no am i losing on time
break this open um five defend oh I
dropped my bishop okay I'm losing this
and I cannot rely on the clock so easily
I got to stir up some trouble somehow
four seconds keep pressure on them
they're in a pin they're still in a pin
okay I'm getting some activity actually
okay they they're in there close to
getting mated they're gonna get mated
they got mated oh that's it oh my
goodness 26 minutes remain Wow Wow
okay c5 no open Sicilian okay oh oh two
seconds all right I should have kicked
the night that was a bad move by me huh
oh boy oh boy oh boy take my bishop I'm
in big trouble very big trouble oh okay
I'm not in trouble anymore watch out for
that bishop I don't know I do that
Bishop here
seconds on push
why'd I do that Queen activity I'm on
the bishop you're gonna see it what does
that move there in a pin just drop back
no matter what
here no matter what hit the Queen I'm on
the rook oh oh oh this is too dangerous
too dangerous a game hit the Queen I
have plenty of time I have ten seconds
now slow down get the Queen's off on the
rook hang on to him back rank mates
wanna hang out of my knight back rank
mates
I got a defend I want to do this just
defend stuff consolidate on that pond
now get some checks okay they're gone
with this King position rook up by
fifteen seconds that I've banked it's
not as you know to be as crazy now um
should just blocked block let's go here
pawn push okay I have everything
connected now why'd I do that okay
rook check take this guy 15 seconds
I'm dropping that okay I have this now
okay they're being sneaky okay they
resigned back to tournament you see if
you bank a lot of time they could end up
going like a real lot but so it's so
hectic right in the early stage they're
78 players
highs are again didn't I did I not oh
you play like the top guy a real lot Wow
okay two seconds
you really have to fly in the early
going and take that night let's pin that
guy six seconds I didn't mean to do that
I did not mean to do that let's get on
this diagonal back up look for mates
Queen d6 get out of that pin as well not
here maybe an idea not here still okay
mmm see with my bishop get a flight
square in no that's a fork I could drop
back eight seconds now why'd I go there
I had to I had a beautiful maid just
Bishop d3 don't move four doubled
backwards move forwards oh man where are
we at a twenty four twenty sixteen
sixteen Heiser again my goodness okay
let's go with uh some quick moves here
of course it's an important strategy you
go with quick moves oh I'm getting
material if I can move and I can force a
queen trade Queen here I have that
square covered enough that's with check
and I get to take here they resigned
back to tournament
twenty eight twenty eighteen twenty less
than again again Wow
I was hoping for a pretty move like
Bishop f5 oh just banking sometime here
take there is the Nikon to take back
oh they lost on time again it's a lot of
games in oh my goodness one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten games
in less than nine minutes whoo gotta go
fast time banking you got to do some
time banking in the early stage no time
burning time banking it's a wonderful
strategy I'm on the bishop he's
unprotected I'm not gonna Castle so
quick let's get off of that file isolate
upon let's take here keep my keep this
Bishop here now I'm gonna castle but
unlike Discovery zones
okay let's oh I'm waiting material oh no
I'm not I was an important in-betweener
this is a nice hut for my king let's
defend that sneakiness sneakiness sneak
attack I'll get the Queen hit the rook
and then grab that pond I was being
sneaky there that was those were just uh
scare tactics watch out for the scare
tactics back to tournament
twenty minutes remain Wow feels like a
lot longer oh here we go coming up the
ranks
Oh Oh go faster um I don't know what to
say
trade dogs guard bishops hunt down the
King oh they're gonna take here in
between her or not okay I have time I
have time there's plenty of it now back
up break at that central pawn clean
trade the Queen trade build in the
center defend this pawn my King needs to
get active right now as soon as possible
hold on you've gone far enough
okay I like that there pawn is fixed on
a light square now let's come over here
baby stop it
ooh let's break here hang on
might be sneaky somehow Oh Mouse slip
okay ah let's do this I guess you've
gone far enough that's another pawn
fixed on a dark square gonna get active
um right here oh boy Oh King here
there's no fear from dr. Seuss mode
watch out for dr. Seuss happens from
time to time check to matter with you
you're oh I'm on the frock I forgot I
was on the rook okay it's clearly under
control now back to tournament they
resigned Wow
oh we're gonna end up having a ton of
games if we stay up here this is gonna
be crazy
no we're not paired up yet okay that's
how it works the top players get paired
up in the standings ah there's a free
pun oh they didn't take it he was a
freebie and a half ah man I just cannot
stop laughing it happens it's clearly
happening okay let's clamp down on that
dark square Bishop exchange pawn push
let's get in g5 let's not get forked I
was ready to get forked there break down
the dark squares babysit my knight
why did I go into a pin I only have
three seconds castle you need to castle
oh boy oh boy
hopefully one of my Knights could be
dangerous
that's not dangerous enough hit the
Queen okay I only have three seconds oh
I got a free Queen
sorry I got loud there no go go go oh
man move Knight are they resigning they
resigned no they timed out back to
tournament we're not even at the halfway
point 44 32 28 he's right on my heels
amazingly DV razor hussar lights oh man
here we go this is a big one
uh what's f6 oh okay got a buildup let's
launch an H pawn close a little bit
alright is it gonna get closed or not
now it's getting opened up let's try my
queen back on my light square Bishop on
g5 we've both done well to Bank a lot of
time okay I'm happy with these exchanges
LightSquared control let's throw that
check in oh that's a that's a killer
isn't it um alright let's do it like
this I felt like I had something else
actually get my bishop here they're
going to close it
they might close it now I'm getting some
material it's getting broken down
probably avoid exchanges get a pawn here
another pawn I have enough time okay
they're gonna do some tactic there
another trade oh I could have shown you
the rook could have taken the rook
that's a good tactic but I'm okay with
trades let's go here they're probably
expecting a check Knight f4 right here
check soon isn't that a good deflection
six seconds when I get rid of their
Knight pins finally every other night
much easier to play much easier to play
now okay all right let me just scoop up
that pond all right I have plenty of
time now back to tournament Oh oh man oh
my goodness there's no time to even
regroup this is not healthy it's
realized I just realized that this time
patrol is just not healthy oh man this
is I think this might be a first and
last I'm shaking shaking hang on your
bishop he's a good man he's a good man
stop 95 Wow I think I need a new Mouse
no what am i doing okay regroup get your
Bishop in here stop them from doing
stuff let's kill that Knight and cement
your rook right here he's getting
another piece here will not be denied
yeah that was not a good idea on my part
let's open stuff up right here my rook
is a beast Oh should take in there okay
can I track that pawn down I think I
have that pawn check
I'm on the rook and that's me oh my
goodness it's not healthy this time
control is unhealthy unhealthy not just
for your chest I'm talking just regular
health here rule I felt not just chess L
oh my goodness Wow Wow
I'm sorry I just cannot stop giggling
laughing what I don't know what you call
it
try for a quick mate quick mate they
might go for fork
they went for Florrick made on G to my
h2s neighbor 12 minutes remain
56:48 38 33 31
Wow okay mm chess I can't you have no
time to read the name forget about
trying to read the name Bishop d3 Queen
e2
some quick moves I have plenty of time
okay
regroup here it's actually not as a it's
not as crazy as you're making it out to
be okay quick mate no that's just that's
just a cheapo let's see if they move
their pond oh they're trying to get me
back try to make me I'll try they're
ready to meet me on g2 now mass
exchanges they're gonna have a minority
attack yeah let's stick my knight right
here he can be very well placed they
might still do before okay um let's
maybe be a pest to that night get rid of
him okay let's back up again here I'm
not quite sure why okay my knight is a
beast now f4 King position could g5 f f5
stop there Knight go for a little King
walk I've probably missed a bunch of
Forks
King position why go off of that file
put pressure back on this guy okay there
you go
now let's break this down that's a check
that pawns falling now actually I get to
push and then Queen that's that's good
and then everything's traded actually
return it back to tournament ten minutes
remain
oh man let's try the caro-kann okay
Queen trades get this night out
threatening a fork okay I have the dark
squares now I get my dark square Bishop
on this dog and all the five is real
nice home now pin the night several
exchange is going to happen yeah let's
let's just play for this uh against the
pawn structure whoa um okay oh I
probably should have just taken that
take with the pawn they're gonna break
that down still I guess you are
I gotta neutralize that rook pawn push
they might do oh they're very active I'm
gonna stay active with my King though
get this pawn they're gonna wipe out my
ax i sided the board here let's keep
running okay I'm getting a passed pawn
my rook is in the perfect spot
cannot be stopped now my pawn oh I'm in
check I don't even realize it was my
move there I should have moved forward
move forward keep moving forward I can
give that pawn up I'm getting a queen
now plenty of time they were trying to
be sneaky there so now queen is ready to
be on the scene there sixty sixty four
forty eight forty thirty-eight
thirty-seven less than nine minutes
remain
96-97 players are in this 100 faster go
faster Bank sometime in the early stage
okay keep the tension and we're going to
drop this guy back a night before stuff
is there let's stop that still keep the
tension now let's do this I might end up
in something tricky over here mmm
it's trade we have four seconds he
doesn't have much either okay they're
going to open up their diagonal I need
to get out there and not deal with you
okay let's glue my rook right in there
okay let's put some pressure pressure
open up the diagonal Queens hit its
check hit the Queen take this pawn the
holder down on time back to tournament
oh we got to peek scary I guess with the
Queen oh we're back at it ah the Benoni
efore knight here they're going to take
okay I will take the light-square bishop
exchange oh okay
let's reposition my Knight to e4
I have a super knight on e4 now I will
go for this trade and now I'm mopping up
this side here getting the rook actually
definitely getting the rook I just want
to get my queen back over here
consolidate everything so keep my pawn
let's just open this up welcome more
trades just defend everything nine
seconds plenty of banked time here Queen
trade everything is a clear from here
oops
oh they resigned that's why I couldn't
move haha was that a booth of stuff
happening with my screen there that a
little highlight stuff prepared again
yeah I didn't know you could be paired
like oh I didn't mean to do that
Swiss cheese over here oh that's a
valuable pun maybe they're gonna repair
my structure a little bit they did okay
oh they're giving me up
oh they're giving me a night I love that
let's block let's drop back the hitting
stuff they're not gonna sack are they
that's a free pawn isn't it it's a free
night I'm on h7 they resigned Baxter
oh man okay ah I should take and we're
gonna have the Donny no no thank you I
don't want to uh allow that right here
and they'd hear stuff watch out
going fishing early this could be scary
Bishop f4 let's block I want to kick
that night out of there like real soon
all right I go back I go back let's get
that night out of there before it's too
late
let's stop Knight c4 develop I'm
dropping that pawn let's take oh hang on
to him let's hit the rook that is really
greedy what I'm doing right here that is
really really greedy I only have two
seconds do you really think you could
calculate if that's good enough good or
not what are you saying two seconds
we're still just playing off of the
increment of course of course that's all
you're doing let's retreat bring every
piece home why don't you throw your
knight on b8 how can i maneuver my
knight to be eight oh man
I'm on that pond take Oh
he's free my goodness was he free open
stuff up get here move bishop
I'm on there bishop right here I'm on g3
here no matter what they're down on time
back to tournament I was putting some
pressure on them there the clock easily
burns when you throw splits oh man crazy
crazy crazy variant we have here yeah I
should have just taken that pond he was
a freebie didn't have the time to figure
it out though Castle I'm dropping this
guy I should just oh they're in a pen oh
boy this is gonna be painful
the queen is hit twice double attack on
the Queen there goes a bishop and the
Knights hit let's get rid of him he's a
pest watch out for bee to sniff that
pond though coast is clear
f5 is collapsing Oh what'd I just say
watch out for bee - oh no I got a crawl
up into a ball
terrible oh there goes my rook ah I was
just saying watch out for bee - ah and I
have no no tricks no tricks
well they have 4 seconds but yeah um my
Kings a fighter he's a fighter my Kings
a fighter tricks right here can I get
the Queen why is this game still going
on they're gonna take my pawn oh my
goodness
I kind of have hope not really uh yeah
it's a long road ahead
I better resign this oh man I just said
watch out for b2y type remove Queen
takes f5 I have a cushion I have a
question I wasn't even looking at the
scores there was no time to look at the
scores ah
alright this will probably no I don't
know if this will be the last game this
isn't a one-time a one-minute time
control keep going uh okay let's back up
rook on c1 now Bishop on e3 would have
been better meat on each seven remove
the night mate nope not quiet let's get
out of this
let's take here I'm on h6 Queen trade oh
they missed that they resigned back to
tournament there's still a minute left
oh man okay
one more game or two less than a minute
I have to try some cheap tricks here
rook I'm on the rook
let's get rid of that Knight know that
guy it's trade and they here no matter
what I can't believe I dropped B - that
was my I even mentioned it to myself I
said just don't don't drop B - what did
you do you drop B - shame on you
bishop here trade some more you're up a
rope eighteen seconds
Oh sneak attack they resigned back to
tournament eleven ten seconds left
seven six five four three two one
they're not going to start another one
that should be it the Bray arena has
officially been
finished all right
am I missing anything all right
good games all okay um
103 took part in this 84 60 to 57 52 47
47 I think this might be the last one I
ever do like this it's really - way too
intense way too intense here's everyone
that took part in it is giving a quick
skim here so we could see yeah that's
that was a bit much I said that when I
played the Horde chess tournament uh
this was a maybe another one too much
too much it's not uh it's not scrolling
down anymore there we go and that's
everybody all right - the 103 of you
that took part in this tournament that I
created here the Bray arena
all right Gigi's
you